a German chancellor Olaf Schultz is
holding talks in Athens amongst the
topics on the agenda are the EU energy
crisis and Turkish challenges to
Greece's sovereignty over a number of
islands in the Eastern Mediterranean
also featuring prominently in the
meetings are efforts to help Ukraine in
its war with Russia to this end Vernon
has been sending tanks to Greece as D.W
Simon young explained
Germany came up with the idea of
supplying tanks to Ukraine via third
countries shortly after the start of the
war
Berlin wanted to help Ukraine but said
it did not have the capacity to send
tanks directly some politicians felt it
was unacceptable for German heavy armor
to be used in a region where Nazi troops
fought in the Second World War
another argument Ukrainian Armed Forces
needed to be supplied as quickly as
possible with systems for which they
would not need training
So the plan was born countries with
soviet-era military equipment would send
that to Ukraine and would receive modern
materiel from Germany to replace it
agreements like this have been announced
with both Slovenia and the Czech
Republic as well as Greece
Poland has also sent many of its Soviet
era tanks to Ukraine but is disappointed
with what Berlin has offered as a
replacement
Germany has delivered some heavy
equipment directly to Ukraine including
self-propelled howitzers
but the drawn out discussion and the
delay in agreeing these tank exchanges
by a third countries has led to calls
for Berlin to bite the bullet and send
its modern tanks directly something that
the Kiev government has repeatedly asked
for
let's go more Matt from our DW's
Emmanuel Shaz uh welcome Emmanuel so
clearly this war sparking differences
between European partners
exactly we've just uh talked about tanks
we see just how difficult it is to
coordinate to decide which weapons are
sent to whom and then which are pledged
to Ukraine in return so there are
disagreements when it comes to defense
uh about the quantity of things that are
being sent about the timing as well and
of course one of the biggest bones of
contention in the European Union is how
to face the energy crisis that is a
result of Russia's war against Ukraine
there are a number of member states
which wants to have a price cap on gas
prices this is something that Germany
opposes this morning Olaf Schultz was
talking to a Greece Prime the Greek
Prime Minister Greece don't doesn't
oppose those uh price capsule Germany
it's actually quite isolated on the
European stage when it comes to that
it's also single handily decided to
unblock 200 billion euros to try and
face the increasing prices so Europe has
to have a show of unity but we see there
are many uh crucial issues key issues
defense energy where well they still
have to agree on how to proceed and
there's an escalation amongst NATO
members that these leaders are trying to
fix
well yes escalation between NATO members
this morning Olaf Schultz offered a
grease his support Germany's support
against the claims by a turkey
over the sovereignty of some of uh the
Greek Islands some inhabited uninhabited
sorry Greek Islands into Eastern
Mediterranean Sea the chancellor said
that this was an acceptable that for one
a NATO member to question the
sovereignty of another and to see one
NATO member making more or less vague
threats and these comes at a time where
Unity is crucial when NATO is really
trying to show Unity so another thing
that has been discussed today in Athens
between the chancellor and the Greek
Prime Minister we're intrigued by this
this idea of Germany which has always
been such a hugely a pro EU country
being so isolated amongst its EU and
NATO partners how much of that is is
because of the the nature of the
Coalition that is currently ruling the
country
perhaps you know Germany has often been
at odds when it came to dealing with
economic matters in the European Union
you know back in 2009 uh Germany had
become hugely unpopular by forcing
Greece to accept three uh International
bailouts to deal with its financial
crisis now Germany is talking about
solidarity but we see that sometimes
it's still very much you know make
decisions on its own rather than
Consulting the partners first we also
saw some decent some disagreement with
friends that were talked over yesterday
uh with France's president Emmanuel
macron's I would say there are
disagreements within the European Union
that being said of course Germany is
still striving for Unity there thank you
for that Andy W's Emmanuel in Berlin